how's it going everyone Lauren here and
spider-man into the spider-verse was an
amazing movie this is going to be a
non-spoiler review so if you're worried
about anything being spoiled for the
movie don't worry I'm not gonna be going
into big details just talking about the
key points that I really enjoyed about
the movie and I'm giving away an
Infinity Gauntlet so be sure to
subscribe like and comment so you can
enter the giveaway for your chance to
win so like I said spider-man into the
spider verse was an amazing movie not
that I doubted it I was just concerned
going into it because I wanted them to
give Miles Morales justice and they did
it was a great on screen premiere for
him and it was a great origin story but
most importantly it was different and
different in a really good way
it wasn't your typical Spider Man story
that we've seen a handful of times and
I'm not saying the other ones are bad
but we know the story so this is a nice
refreshing change while also staying
true to Spider Man and Miles Morales and
a big part of it being different was the
fact that it was an animated movie but
again it wasn't a typical animated movie
it was very different in its own great
way it was very slick and it was very
fast which made for some great action
scenes and it was very comic like like I
was watching a comic come to life it was
really like I was watching a comic on
the big screen it was really really cool
and they blended everything together
really really well
the movie had so many aspects to it that
just worked the story was really good
and it had a lot of action to it it had
a lot of character development and build
up it was really really funny one of the
greatest things about this movie which
was brilliant is seeing all of the
different spider-man and spider people
from different multiverses coming
together and interacting and it wasn't
done in a really weird chaotic way the
story made sense it did justice to miles
this origin story and then you had this
version of Peter Parker who has been
spider-man for a really really long time
helping miles who has no idea how to be
spider-man and then you have the other
spider people come in from the other
multiverses and really bring the movie
together
you have spider-gwen who is one of my
personal favorite web-slinger's we had
spider-man you are who was a really good
character to have in there and he was
hilarious
you have penny Parker who was this sort
of animated girl in the movie which
added a completely different aspect to
it but again it really fit and the
dynamic between her character and the
rest of the spider people worked
extremely well and then you had spider
ham in there which was probably my least
favorite not that I didn't like him but
I just enjoyed the other spider people
much more than I did spider-ham but
there are many people that said that he
was hilarious and they loved him and
again they made him fit very well with
the rest of the group and the movie I
loved the character development of Miles
Morales and I loved that Peter Parker
was there to help him he doesn't just
jump right into being spider-man it
takes him some time to learn he freaks
out at first as anybody would if you got
bit by a radioactive spider and all of a
sudden had powers so he has to deal with
that and he has to deal with being in
middle school and he has to deal with
parents who loved him but smother him
about getting good grades so he has to
figure all of that out and then he asked
Peter Parker there to help him and then
he has the rest of the spider people
come in and they encourage him as well
and the fight scenes are really awesome
because you have a bunch of different
spider people fighting a bunch of
different villains I love how they
incorporated different villains you're
gonna have multiple spider people you
might as well have multiple different
villains it was almost like taking five
different action scenes from five
different movies and slamming them into
one and they did it in a really
brilliant way and to top it all off the
music was really really good it got me
super hyped up I've already downloaded
some of the songs that were in the movie
basically everything just worked
everything about the movie came together
the stories the animation the action the
character developments the character
interactions the music it all came
together for an overall amazing movie so
that's my non-spoiler review on
spider-man into the spider verse it hit
theaters last night on December 13th so
go check it out
and don't forget to subscribe like and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything related to Marvel
spider-man into the spider-verse
and Avengers and game as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you